[Music]
always on the lookout for exciting new
guests to perform on the show yeah right
that's what constantly on the lookout
well lately we've been hearing a lot of
buzz about a hot new act in Vegas okay
they sent us a video of this guy's act I
thought it'd be fun if we all watched it
together I haven't seen it yet but I
hear he's the biggest thing in Vegas
he's a big biggest stage okay so let's
all take a look together the Vegas Strip
is shining brighter than ever thanks to
its newest star
so it's Corey Lutz man of a thousand
videos sit back and relax as Corey shows
you all his favorite videos on YouTube
so uh this guy is playing dragon force
on expert in a Guitar Hero whew it's a
97%
it's three and a half straight hours of
YouTube videos played off Cory's iPhone
okay so this one they cut it so it
sounds like this parrot is singing Daft
Punk the sounds kind of shitty so maybe
just you know lean forward a little bit
Kurt stange from the Vegas Sun raves the
videos are almost as good as the ones my
son shows me LPTV says his screen was
pretty smudged but the videos were okay
only Cory delivers non-stop
entertainment with occasional breaks to
rest his arm and charge his phone anyone
have a charger so join Cory six nights a
week at the 3000 seat Cory Lutz theater
so this makes about the fight this guy
now no wait no no
[Music]
what later career Lutz
man of a thousand videos only in Vegas
Cory Lutz also appearing in Cirque de
Soleil spiral at a I'll see you in Vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
that's abusive entertainment